Pick up the camera and let's go.
Thanks.
Hi, Stacie.
Hi.
I wonder why the peas were playing with the mini Maka and Konra dolls again.
Well, they're good now, so we shouldn't be making fun of them.
Yeah, but the kids...
Hey, Dodgers!
What is it?
It's Leyva, Korok, and Galak.
Oh, you formed into a Bohrok-Kaita.
Yeah, we did.
Now, if we need to battle again against the evil Bohrok, then we can go into this thing
and battle.
Okay, well, you better...
Show us how you fold up.
I can't fold up.
This is just how I think I fold up.
And then you put your arms around here?
Yeah.
It's cool today.
Yeah, you go.
That's good.
Two years, Stacie.
What is it?
Yes?
Oh, it's a puzzle.
Yeah.
Oh, you're a Tohunga.
Oh, you live in Mata Nui?
Well, how'd you get a walkie-talkie?
You don't know?
Oh.
Well...
Bye, guys!
Well, um...
You better...
You better, uh...
Bohrok?
Yeah, we'll take care of it.
I don't know about this.
Stacie!
The evil Bohrok, of course.
Mm.
Where is Stacie?
Stacie, she left her school.
Where's Matt?
I don't know.
I found it in a...
In a...
In a garbage can.
I washed it off, because it was laminated.
All right, we gotta...
Look!
We gotta do battle plans.
Set up all the battle plans.
You just keep doing them about your stuff.
To talk about...
To Stacie about something.
Does she have her cell phone with her?
Does Stacie have her cell phone with her?
Yeah, I think...
Yeah, I think she does.
Okay.
I'm gonna call her now.
Dang!
It skips.
Guys, we just got a call on the hotline.
We have to be around.
Okay.
Oh, can you skip school?
Thanks, Stace.
I'm building out a map of Mount Sinui so we know where to go.
I'm gonna go pick up Stacie.
She said she can skip school.
Okay.
I got this map last year.
We haven't won on vacation, but now we're putting it to a good use.
Please, Mom.
You oughta...
Careful driving.
You're too fast.
Hi, guys.
The teacher said since I'm skipping...
Since I have something to do, I have to bring my homework along.
Okay.
I don't know why, but will my homework get destroyed when you get out in battle?
No.
You keep it here.
The teacher said wherever I go...
Stacie.
What?
You're just here with us.
You're not actually battling.
We're gonna send the tele.
Just don't tell them that.
They're gonna go wild.
Okay.
Because they want to go back...
But I always go...
Um...
Why can't I just die?
Just...
Because...
No real reason.
I can finally do my homework.
I don't think so.
At least I don't know.
Forgot to feed Sparky.
Do Sparky again.
Feed for just two weeks.
Your cookie, Sparky.
Suvacaita.
To my...
Samantha.
Me.
Hello.
It's hard putting a map together.
I can see.
I'm gonna need a piece right there.
Looks like a little path.
Horse.
How's Martinande's family?
Not only that...
Let's get the bay.
I want to know everything about her.
Cause that's on my 40.
I didn't know she was born in China.
It's a viola city.
She was born in China and moved to England.
Must have been hard adjusting to the place.
Time is going sample our map is complete.
Stacy and Jack started planning.
Her old horse had worms.
Stacy Anna wants to ride that horse.
homework? We're supposed to be planning. Patamy. No Stacy I don't trust Patamy. I
trust her when she goes to her room. Okay can you come over here please? Sure.
Don't get Sparky all messy. Stacy put that book down. Now you will be talking to Anua,
Kopaka and Gally over your walkie-talkie. I'll be talking to the other toe. See
there's Tahu. Tahu, Lewa and Pohatu will come here with their little guys.
Just just pretend they're there. Okay and then? These guys will start right here.
Yeah they'll move to each of their villages. Takoro. There's two swarms
there.
So we'll mark off the swarms. Okay now where's Kokoro's over here? I'm gonna try and find out the swarms.
Now we have the advantage because we have um right there Anu Koro. Now they'll
each protect their village. They'll each eliminate the swarms in their area or
collect six krana from each swarm. Then they'll all head to the main temple right
here.
Get your walkie-talkies ready. We're
ready to send the toe on the mission. We got to set up a meeting.
This is my plan book. I got to get my pencil so I can write this down. It might be coming in the newspaper.
You never know. Okay toe, you're helping us. Gonna be famous!
This is a secret from the ones who have formed into a Boracayita. There were six of them.
This is a secret from the ones who have formed into a Boracayita. Because they're one-two's.
It'll be safe. This will be safe. Just stay here. Okay. anew. This is a secret from the ones who have formed into a Boracayita. Because they're one-two's.
They're gonna want to battle me.
Meeting come to order.
Now, in our first plan, each Toa will go to their village.
Got that everybody?
Yeah!
Now, okay.
Each of them will get six, each of you guys will get six krana, six different krana for each swarm in their, in your area.
Then you will head to the main temple.
And inside, you will defeat the main threat.
And then we'll mind control every Bohrok that's left on the island.
And then they'll become, and Mata Nui will be on the AC's legs then.
And then, um, and then the Bohrok will be in the super, in the AC's army.
Got that everybody?
Yeah.
Okay, we got warp pads.
The warp pad is right here.
You got to go in here to get to Mata Nui.
Lewa, you go first.
And Mata.
Next Tohu.
Polatu's next.
They should have landed separately.
The lid this time.
We can't walk around without our masks.
Ready to go?
Me and I don't have my mask clustered.
Locked it.
Okay.
So no, hey wait a minute, there's no Bohrok here.
Yes it is.
Stay close.
Hide it behind your back.
Yes sissy.
Hey there's another Krona.
No, it's carrying two Krona.
Are you a Bohrok?
Yes.
Well here's a Krona.
No, here's two Kronas.
Thank you.
Hey there's one carrying three Krona.
Are you a Bohrok?
We are.
Here is three Krona.
We collected all six.
Our work here is done.
Yep.
That was easy.
Let's put them in our, now let's put them in our bedroom.
In the drawer.
But careful sis.
Maybe we should just lay them out here for one minute.
We gotta get you it.
This is Dr. Senor.
Do you have all six Krona from that, from the Khorok hive?
Yes.
Well then head to the temple.
Alright.
Get in your case to travel.
Should we go to the temple?
Should we put the Krona in?
No.
Where should we put them?
They'll follow you.
Cool.
Go in sis.
We're riding in this case again.
Who said that?
Kamo, we gotta battle.
If there are any here.
See if any Bohrok come.
Are you worried about this big bro?
Yeah.
I'm sure.
Now why aren't there any Bohrok around?
There should be some.
Sit down here until any come.
If they do come.
Then we can gather some Krona.
Rumbling sound.
No.
They're Bohrok.
Be quiet.
Some of them might be carrying more than one Krona.
I don't want to use this properly.
Well we got two Krona.
It looks like one but it's actually two.
Now.
Where should we get more Krona?
This is right here good.
But wait a minute.
Let's move farther into the hive.
Well we entered more of the hive.
Let's see.
But Kamo.
You just take a rest.
I'll search around for Bohrok.
Especially Bohrok.
Bah.
They're always carrying Krona.
So far we've got two out of six Krona that we need.
Hey.
What's that?
Bohrok sound.
That chicken three Krona.
We only need one more Krona.
Are you a Bohrok?
Attack him.
Yeah.
We blew the Krona out of it.
It's close.
Take it off.
Too hard to get off.
Ah.
There.
Now we have all the Krona we need.
Let's go.
Let's get out of this hard place.
We're here.
Keep moving.
I'm sure if you can hold it.
I can hold it.
See.
Well that's a pretty good weapon for you.
Now I'll have to use your little saw thing.
Lock this house.
I'm nervous about this.
This house is too big.
Can we like trade?
I like my other one.
Okay.
That sort of is.
I'm kind of scared too.
I've got news from Tahu and Kopaka that they've collected all the Krona they need.
Tahu encountered some Bohrok and Kopaka did too.
I sure hope we don't encounter any.
Close.
There.
He almost caught you.
That one's carrying a Krona.
Get it Matah.
It go back to the A.C. and not have their head on.
I don't.
It's another Bohrok Vah.
It wants the Krona back.
We have two Krona.
Okay.
I'm going to take my mask off.
It's kind of hot thing deserves to be gone. Hey, it's gone. We have
Three crime because that one it just flung at us was three
Which two so we have three car. Well, that's a good thing. That's thing. Give me a creeps
Yeah, it's like the willies out of me. Hey, that one's carrying a different colored car
grayish
Stay away from it. I'll take care of this one. Yes three. We have four common now
Good thing. I thought it was it thought we were dead
It'll be like that. Oh, oh, sorry
We only need one more car and there it is
It's cool. There's a there's a poor up five. They're carrying it ran away without even picking up its car
Cool. Now we have all the carna we need
Let's go don't bring your blanket
Now go it up and last time my head. Oh, there it is
We better not go anywhere where any of these those things are because I
Don't have my mask or my weapon or anything on me either says
Well, I don't know the map. I always kind of can afford it
Are you able rock here are two chrono?
One I live
All right
I don't know and it's annoying here. Oh, yeah, I got a way for you hang out. It's kind of weird here, isn't it?
It's kind of hot. I just sit here for a bit
until some
a
Better have to go
Let me put on your mask
you know, you're gonna get on in your
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
We got five Krona.
Wow, that thing must have been much.
That's five Krona.
No, no, meow, no, no, no.
Hey, there's one more Krona over there.
It's being carried by that Bohrok.
Oh, Bohrok.
It's in its head.
That's where all Krona are.
No, no, meow.
Eat me.
I'll get you.
I'll help you.
Man, that was easy.
now we gotta leave this place it's hot in here that is the last time we travel
by air hey my head ready to go yeah we are last time I battle I blew into
pieces let's just hope I don't blow into tiny pieces this time don't worry you
won't okay we're just gonna have to wait until the bow rock
it's carrying a two product but it's carrying a three car get it no I'll take
care of this little bro don't you know you're new know new lock new lock what
are you doing here I came to visit Mozzanilli here's three car I get I got
thanks
I got it. I gotta go act like I'm a bull rock until you guys are finished
Well, thank you. That was easy
Well here we are at the temple
Who's for who's ready to go inside first?
I am four of us are going in in our cases down. We're gonna battle. What's ever in there
Let's get ready all right
Everybody ready to go inside well here we are
inside the tunnel mean the temple
Wonder what's in here? Hey? What's that?
There's something over there. It's coming down for the sky is it Holly you'll go first
You just need to watch it because it's got scrapers here. It's eyes
Okay, now battle and show them who's boss. This is the weakest creation
I've ever made after if I defeat you this time, then I'll be able to get more health too bad
I don't have anybody
to
To obey me
Shit, it's too bad. I don't have anything to command
But this is my weakest form
Bad because if I'm defeated then I won't be have a chance. I'll be gone from the earth forever
But you already were wait a minute. I'm not Makuta
I'm part of Makuta
I'm evil spirit from Makuta
Makuta.
Makuta, Makuta, Makuta.
To war.
I am the evil spirit of Makuta.
I'm not as strong as the real one.
The real one wasn't strong.
I'm going to use this.
Isn't she going to change mask?
I thought I saw that.
I'm going to.
I'm waiting.
I don't.
I'm putting on my pretty mask.
How does this thing go on again?
It's ready.
You knocked off your arm after you knocked off mine.
She is the fierce one who attacks me while I'm doing it again.
I swear your body will be laid in this hive.
I can't believe I have to use sport and a secret stupid.
Your crown.
I'm putting my crown in a new place.
My sovereign.
You don't even know where my crown is.
Did you know that I know where your crown is?
I'm wondering why she never uses her shielding mask.
Even though she doesn't have it anymore.
I guess I do.
Uh oh.
I shouldn't have said that.
Now I'm wearing it.
You will have nothing to do about this.
Pick it.
How do you know?
I like that.
Yes it will.
You're knocked out anyway.
Give me.
I can't even put this on.
Then you can get back.
I failed.
Toa Paka.
Yes.
I'm here to take Gally's mask back.
Give it back.
Yeah.
You'll have to go first.
I'm going to kick your butt.
Because I'm cool.
I'll get you for this.
I can't believe that
Pucked you up with this move.
But it's too hard.
Feinted yet?
I'm ready to battle spirit of Makuta!
Well, I'll destroy you!
Well.
I knocked off your mask.
Not.
Yeah.
What are you doing?
Muju is going to activate the mask.
The Mask Breaker.
She's giving out her mask.
Because you were dead in the head.
Why do they always say that?
I must meditate.
And I must meditate too.
Marow, marow, marow, marow.
Meditation.
What the heck was that?
Watch this.
Hey, that was really freaky.
Let's battle, Makuta.
This is a duplicate of my last body.
Getting back on my canoe.
I'll get that back on.
If I can find it, where did my mask go?
I'm getting up.
We're going to have Mwaka and Conra.
That tells me that you're a weakling without Mwaka and Conra.
They were better fighters than you were.
They were brave enough to go up and fight.
Maybe just the spirit, but you are kind of tough.
I know if I'm defeated this time, I'll be going for the earth forever.
It's going to be easier to get off.
That little bro.
I'll be able to take care of you, Makuta.
Spirit.
I'll put on this mask.
Cool.
Catch him.
Maybe it's not fit for me.
Or I'm going to use my water breathing.
It's a clear colored mask that looks like others.
I'm going to water.
At least I've got Gally's mask.
He can't get it up here if he's swimming in the water.
He got it.
He got the mask back.
And now I'm going to use it.
Try to attack him.
He's going to block us.
See?
Just to show you that I don't.
That I only use others.
Watch this.
I guess telemasks don't work with good with Turaga.
I got my normal mask.
I'm about to on Nua.
Believe to me.
I hope he doesn't use a special move.
But Makuta, then that's what you're going to get.
What he's going to do.
Try to attack me.
I don't believe that it will block every move this time.
You should have known it.
I'm changing masks.
What the heck is that?
I've never heard of that.
The mask of experience.
Explosive strength is purple or bright violet.
Fusion.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
And then this type, black mask or white.
This type.
Darn it.
Turn it off.
Turn it.
Why did I even try that?
What should I do?
I know.
I'll use my water breathing mask.
I can turn the ground into water.
Warm.
I'm right here, Makuta.
Warm, warm, warm, warm, warm, warm, warm.
Darn it.
Looks like my chances for survival are pretty slim.
What is he doing under there?
He's been under there for quite a while.
Get him.
I don't remember that.
I need a new head, man.
It's just a normal rock.
Bling, bling, bling, bling, bling, bling.
Put that rock away.
Back you.
Makuta, give me that good mask.
I'll keep it tight hold of it.
Hello, brother.
Brother, you've taken hold of it.
I'm not your little brother.
Huh?
Oh, yeah.
He's got an infected mask on.
You can pull hot, too.
I don't believe that.
He put an infected mask on your face.
It's time for you to rest.
Okay.
I really wanted to battle.
Because that's what the infected mask does to you for a bit.
So you can go inside our case and rest.
All right.
Now you will pay for all that you have done.
It is my honor.
Hyper Shield.
Stand away, Hyper Shield.
I will get rid of you.
No, you won't.
You're updating my gold mask.
It can change into any mask.
Looking for me, Makuta?
What's going on under there?
We've been plotting a plan right behind our backs.
It's the Kamui.
Great mask of levitation.
I can float in the air.
Get him.
Hyper Super Kick.
That's because you are a weakling.
He can get away with it.
Super Speed.
Kamui Super Kama.
This is a light orange color.
He's going super fast.
You can't swim with that.
Who is next to challenge me?
Let me get some board.
Oh, I know who it is.
Lewa.
Yes, it is.
But I will destroy you, Makuta.
To save Tahu some slack.
Tahu?
Hmm.
Well, I'll destroy you.
All right, Morin.
We'll battle you, Makuta.
But little bro must go first.
Who's little bro?
It's a butt.
Butts are ugly to me.
Before he hits me again.
I had this mask.
Just a second.
Throw it, Makuta.
Ha.
I'm changing masks.
Who the heck is he?
He knew one.
Defeated them.
Too weird.
What could it be that is so...
So...
What is this?
I just...
I just want to know.
Why does it blind my ears?
Have failed.
No.
To challenge me.
Tahu?
Yes.
The fiercest Tahu.
Makuta.
We will battle.
And we'll decide...
Who...
If you are to be on this earth again.
But first, my little brother must go.
Did he turn...
I'm changing masks.
To control your mind.
I was going to keep...
Give me back my weapon.
Take this mask off.
Quick.
Makuta.
Your eyes look different.
They're reddish.
Yes.
I got some surgery.
Now.
I will defeat you.
Just keep a tight hold on it.
So you can't use it.
Cheater.
Ha.
You don't have a go...
Anymore.
Yes, I do, Makuta.
I have two.
Yes.
What is he doing?
It's the Kanoe Kaukau.
Where's he going?
Go.
Got to...
Now what do we do?
I'm just going to have to be pummeled by me.
Got to change him.
I don't have any other masks.
Except my Kanoe Miru.
Kanoe Miru?
Yeah.
Like Lei was.
Except it's red.
Come on, Makuta.
My sword is like a whip.
Got to change him.
I just created a new mask.
What is it?
Why do you need to know, freak?
You told me that wasn't possible.
I don't know.
Ugh.
There's a scar on my face.
From last time, Makuta.
You are the weakest evil that I have ever met.
Oh?
That's a Toa Kaita.
As Tanok mentioned in that one movie, it is true for...
A Toa Kaita is true.
Spatula.
Get him.
It's pretty good, Makuta, but not good enough.
Hit him.
He blocked it.
Yes, I did.
Powerful enough to defeat me.
Except maybe Dr. Shiniora, but he's on our side.
Pepper, he wants to save his life, because...
What was that voice?
It was my illusion.
Illusions.
I'm a Toa Kaita.
We're Hiura.
Made out of Gally, Lewa, and...
And, um...
Kopaka.
This is a Toa Kaita.
This is my weapon.
Ha ha.
I can block many attacks.
And I can kick.
Whoops.
Now, I must battle for more.
I didn't know that you would form into a Toa Kaita.
Toa Kaitas are much more powerful than the Toa.
They're more powerful than all the Toa that it's made out of combined.
And even their attacks with it.
What's that up there?
Oh, well.
Let's get back to battle.
Get him!
I'm changing mass, Makuta.
You look different.
Well, I'm still the same one, except I can see any of your attacks.
But I can't float in the air.
I put it into water.
You, Makuta.
He, you are we...
What is he doing?
Hey, he's taking longer this time.
Finish you Bakuda!
My mission...
No more Bakuda.
Nooooooo!
You win, you win, you win! I'll play, I'll play, I'll play!
Ugh!
Get away, rodent!
The super family has defeated me for the third time.
Get away, you freak!
Gally, how the heck are we gonna get off this island?
Well...
We can't fly off because our canisters are gone with fuel, but Mata Nui's already on the legs.
But we have these masks, and we can fly away, but, um...
But we don't...
Um...
But we can't leave our canisters here.
Well, we could dry our canisters behind us.
No, they're too heavy.
It will counteract our Miro masks, like the one I have here.
Oh, but we're gonna have to find another way out. We already mind-controlled the Bohrok.
Yes, that is true.
And now they're in the AC's army, so we can use them in the war.
But they will never die, so that's good, because we have a huge army.
Yeah...
Um...
Well...
Couldn't we just find a gas station?
There aren't any gas stations on Mata Nui.
It's sort of like tribes around here. They don't have, like, electricity and stuff.
Well...
Let's see if we can find anything to make oil.
Hmm...
That's possible.
I know of a warp pad that goes along the Trin-Chrom bridge.
That goes along the Trin-Chrom break.
That's how we can leave.
Alright.
Do you think we can try that?
I guess.
Okay, that sells it. We're going along the Trin-Chrom break.
Join us on our next video, um...
Uh...
Escape from Mata Nui.
Clean up!
That's a wrap!
Owlbrain, why not? Didn't I tell you?
Chain the prisoner!
The prisoner's between those trees and feed them. Understood?
Warclaw, you and Badrag are in charge.
Three Claws, come with me.
Right, Chief.
But where are we going?
Hunting.
Hunting for slaves.
Your stripedog all chained up. Silly beast.
Why'd you let him do that to you?
We've been captured by Sligar.
Who are you?
Skull Droptail's the name. Too clever to let him chain me up.
Skull Droptail, can you help us?
Why'd Skull help you, silly beast?
Not lending him the keys.
Matty, keys. He's got keys to our locks.
Skull, if you've got keys, we really need your help.
Okay, but it'll cost you. Whatcha got, eh? Come on, whatcha got?
We need something to bargain with. Anything.
My father gave this to me. I bet he's never seen a blue flower before.
This is my Season Day gift from Mum.
It's...
All I've got.
Mum's Champion Climber Tail Bracelet. It's my most precious thing.
Hmm.
Suppose I better throw this in, too. Dad said it belonged to old Abbot Mortimer long before my time.
It's all we have.
Hmm, not much. Not much.
Hmm. Funny bell, though.
A white robe would be nice on, Skull.
Oh, yes. Now try the bracelet on your tail.
Well, Skull, do we have a deal?
Uh, deal.
So, where are the keys?
Uh, don't carry them. Uh, gotta go for them.
All right, but be quick about it.
Did you think I had a key?
Stupid you, Clever!
That's pretty gifts for free!
Ha ha!
Lying, cheating thief!
Grrrr!
Come on, we must be strong. We must try to be strong.
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba! Ooh!
Ha!
Ooh-hoo-hoo-hoo!
Oh, yeah!
Mm-hmm!
Ha-ha-ha!